why's coronavirus killing more men than
women at a higher rate killing men than
women early we had just the case numbers
and death numbers from China and we
immediately saw a much higher rate of
death for men than for women and the
suggestion was that in China culturally
men smoked more than women men are much
more likely to be smoking cigarettes and
we know cigarettes weaken your
respiratory system they can depress your
immune system and because coronavirus
seems to vary a lot depending on the
underlying health condition of the
person infected men were more likely to
die in China because men are much more
likely to be smokers it seemed plausible
in any case the trend though is
continuing in a lot of different
countries and we are now seeing that in
Italy men are 60% of the cases but 70%
of the deaths in South Korea more women
have tested positive but yet the deaths
are 54% men the u.s. so far is not
releasing this detail of a detailed
level of information so we don't know
what's going on here the US should start
releasing that data but in total for all
countries where we have data men are
about 50% more likely than women to die
after being diagnosed now remember 50%
can mean if women have a 2% death rate
and men have a 3% death rate that's 50%
more I don't want people to
misunderstand the the numbers around
that so what's at play here
the smoking issue does seem to be a
factor in possibly alcohol consumption
as well
we have world data from five years ago
and as a five years ago 36 percent of
men over age 15 smoked we're only seven
percent of women over age 15 smoked
that's a big difference and if indeed
smoking is a essentially a comorbidity
with coronavirus that is important
meanwhile alcohol consumption
consumption for men is 11 liters where
it's two liters for women that may be a
factor we saw that SARS and MERS also
had higher death rates for men than
women so it seems not unique to kovat 19
and there's also a general evolutionary
idea
that maybe women have stronger immune
responses to viruses in general because
of pregnancy essentially being living
nine months of your life with a foreign
body inside of you it may confer some
kind of survival advantage there could
be a hormonal element to this and then
also actual pre-existing conditions
appear to be a factor we know that
pre-existing conditions increase
mortality for kovat patients check out
some of the gender differences men more
likely to have heart disease than women
stroke than women COPD a lung disease
and slightly more likely to have high
blood pressure all of these conditions
are known to increase the death rate
from coronavirus so the takeaways are
the death rate is remaining higher for
men than women in all of the countries
providing data we initially heard this
out of China other countries providing
us this data seem to be confirming the
same thing number two the u.s. is not
providing data of this type and the u.s.
really should start so that that's the
second takeaway we're going to continue
following this and see see sort of where
we come up as we get more data